reasontv presents citizens against
government waste is poker of the month
Florida representative Debbie
wasserman-schultz what do you do when
you and your friends in Congress go on a
taxpayer-funded spending binge only to
see massive unemployment and a
floundering economy just say something
that sounds good together contracts to
create more jobs this year than the
entire Bush presidency we will have
created more jobs in this year than in
the entire Bush presidency that sounds
great and according to bureau of labor
statistics data it's also amazingly
disingenuous the entire eight years of
the bush dependency and you can't let me
yes i can not you have said it and you
can totally wrong simply count the
number of jobs gained like over 400,000
temporary census jobs and ignore the
over 3 million jobs lost you cherry
picking the time frame and the trail
does not exist what about it what about
the other former may know what if I we
on in Florida bought for me after
spending 862 billion dollars on a
massively wasteful stimulus package and
seeing the unemployment rate over nine
percent for the last 14 months people
are feeling good about how things are
going right for her dithering
double-talk and deliberate
misrepresentation of the facts citizens
against government waste names
representative Debbie wasserman-schultz
October's porker of the month for more
information about Porter of the month
and other government waste issues visit
CA GW